TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The primary change in the latest
release of the Google Play
services SDK is the introduction
of the new task and GoogleApi
based APIs to replace the
GoogleApiClient access pattern.
Check out the post linked in the
description below for a summary
and code to get started
with the new pattern.
Understanding how
people find your app
and what they do once
they've installed
it is crucial to helping
you make the right product
and marketing decisions.
To help you obtain more
accurate and reliable data
about your installs, we're
introducing the Google Play
Install Referrer API,
which is a reliable way
to securely retrieve
install referral content.
For details and code,
check out the post.
We're cutting the price of
NVIDIA Tesla GPUs attached
to on-demand Google Compute
Engine virtual machines
by up to 36%.
Lower priced GPUs, together with
Custom VM shapes and Sustained
Usage Discounts allow you
to run highly parallelized
compute tasks on GPUs with
strong performance, all
at a great price.
Links to get started
are on the post.
Machine learning and
data driven analysis
can help unlock
valuable insights,
but it's not always easy to
know where or how to start.
To help with that, we're
hosting Cloud OnAir: the Journey
from Big Data to AI on
December 5 in the Americas
and December 6 for
the rest of the world.
It's a global online
event, so everyone can
join no matter where you are.
Links to view the breakout
sessions and register
are on the post.
We're excited to announce
multi-database support
in your Firebase projects, which
makes scaling your Realtime
Database a lot easier.
Check out the post
linked in the description
below for screenshots and code.
Please like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching another
episode of the Developer Show.
If you'd like to catch some
of our previous episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]